hey do you remember the energy when like
50 first came on to shady like oh yeah
like did did you guys know that was
coming down the pipeline did y'all know
that m was just a fan or like like no no
no no oh
50 security uh was
from the queens no no all m security was
from queens
so they kind of put us up on 50 with the
mixtapes and [ __ ]
so it kind of
like gradually grew on them
you know what i'm saying so you know we
you know he he became a fan but yeah
when he
he definitely changed [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying that had to be like that you
had to be security yeah well now i tell
you like i always tell people like i
don't know i think peak snoop dogg and
peak 50 are like the two biggest things
i've ever seen in like hip hop ever yeah
like doggy style snoop get rich or die
trying 50. yeah pandemonium
just
oh yeah insane oh that was it that was
it that was in the same time right
yeah it was like i mean and then
everybody and then just m and 50 going
at every [ __ ] buddy's night going at
murder ain't going to tremaine debris
going in [ __ ]
were you just in like during that time
were you just like openly inheriting
every beef just because [ __ ] it oh yeah
for sure every day yeah we got to be on
point bulletproof vest
security i'm assuming the murder ink
[ __ ] probably got the most serious out
of all that [ __ ] all of it was serious
but uh yeah it was yeah well the moby
beef wasn't serious
[Laughter]
that might have been a serious one of
all i don't know
if i was gonna kill him no i could i
just feel like that they know that
murdering [ __ ] [ __ ] was getting crazy oh
yeah yeah for sure ashanti caused some
strays in that thing man that [ __ ] was
wild man the sideburn line oh my god
and uh
suge like was all
cause she was with them
oh man that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] was
serious it had to have gotten
interesting yeah
but produce some amazing hip hop
yeah a lot of stuff that didn't even
make it to any albums all on mixtapes
all the mixtape [ __ ] was so crazy damn
bringing mixtapes back man
that's like when m r he released uh what
was the 20th anniversary he just did was
it for eminem show yeah
nah now before that he did like an
eminem show re-released and he released
one of the mixtape records that was out
forever but it's on dsps and i was so
[ __ ] excited he just did the curtain
call too and put out some other [ __ ]
but yeah you know well listen man oh
bizarre i appreciate you pulling up bro
oh man thank you for having me man i
look forward to not subscribing to your
only fans oh man
i got two customers so far right